- On this episode, my homie Brian stops by
and talks about his new book.
(upbeat, hip hop music)
You ask questions, and I answer them.
This is the #AskGaryVee Show.
Hey everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk,
and this episode 162 of
the #AskGaryVee Show.
This is a very special episode,
because I just got off the
plane from my family vacation
for my 40th birthday,
so this is the first episode in my 40s.
I'm also here with a very dear friend.
As a matter of fact, Staphon,
I'm gonna have you make an edit.
There has to be video of your last,
I don't, that was your last book,
that was two books ago when we did it?
- Two months ago, when
we were in South By.
- There's video of that somehwere.
Staphon, just show a little cut.
This is us in our younger days, Brian.
- We have none other than Gary Vaynerchuk.
How are you, brother?
- How are you, man?
- Awesome, so,
I've got a book, went out and
bought this really amazing
thing called the Thank You Economy.
You ever heard of it?
- Form what I hear, it's the
greatest business book written
of all time, so I think you
made a very wise $13 decision.
Alright, that was good.
I'll get you that clip,
Staphon, and, Brian,
why don't you tell the
Vayner Nation who you are?
It's really good to have you here,
I'm glad we made it happen.
And you have a new book,
which is really the only
reason my friends stop by
the #AskGaryVee Show,
is to sell their books
to the Vayner Nation,
which I respect, because, in March,
I'll be stopping by everybody's house.
- You will be stopping by my house,
but if it means a lot, though,
I'm actually here to officially welcome
Gary Vee into his 40s,
so he can join my club,
although I think I look
a lot younger.
- You do, man, you have no grays.
- Just a couple here and there.
- How old are you, Brian?
- I am 44.
- You look good, man.
- Well, it's the oil of Olay.
- Do you use that?
- It's red wine, actually.
- Is it?
Well, shit, then I should look 13.
Didn't work for me.
Oh, wait a minute, wait
a minute, wait a minute,
you have to, we continue the trend
of a, I apologize, a VaynerMedia employee.
We were just talking about Orlando, so,
a VaynerMedia employee
joining each episode,
so why don't you tell the
Vayner Nation who you are
and say hello and what
you do and all that?
- I'm Kelly, I'm a community manager here,
I started three months ago,
I'm from Orlando, Florida,
Disney, and yeah, I love it.
I just moved up to New York.
It's great, it's a blast.
Yeah, very different.
- Enjoying?
- [Kelly] Yeah, love it.
- Thanks for joining us.
- [Kelly] Of course.
- Keep going.
- Well, yeah, so.
- We transition quick here, Bri.
- I'm ready, clutch in.
So I'm a digital analyst,
I work at a place called
Altimeter Group, we study
disruptive technology,
it's impact on business.
I'm also a digital anthropologist,
studying disruptive
technology's impact on us.
Have a new book out.
- This is gorgeous, man.
- Incredibly ironic that I'm talking
about disruptive technology
and I'm gonna write a book.
- Look at this.
- Took about three and a half years.
Disney.
- This was three and a half years?
- Yeah, because I studied UX, UI,
and a lot of attention spans, focus,
sentence structure, and
sort of tried to reinvent
what a book could be in 2016,
and if you notice in the pages,
it looks a lot like a mobile app.
- Interesting.
- And so it's designed after
some of the most popular apps,
no table of tentents,
it's all very interesting.
It's about experiences, so
I thought if I'm gonna talk
about experiences, the book
should be an experience.
- Very cool, good for you, man.
How's it going so far?
When's it come out?
- It just came out.
It's going, I think it's
going good, you know.
- Just came out a la when?
- Like, a week ago.
- Got it, last Tuesday.
- Yeah, I think last Tuesday.
So let's see.
- A week from today?
- How this episode goes.
- Last Tuesday, very good.
- You know how Amazon is.
So whenever Amazon gets it, boom.
- Staphon, let's link that
up in Facebook and Youtube.
Vayner Nation, we've had
people come through,
so you know where my words sit on this.
Brian is an early friend of mine
from the early, kind
of like when I entered
the tech space, a quality
human being, you know,
I'm a fan, you know, I
don't read books, Bri,
as you know, which is weird,
but I'm positive that
you put in good effort.
I know that this was definitely,
you've written a lot of books.
So this one seems to be
the biggest break in time,
do you feel great about that, like,
do you feel like this
one you put in more work
than the norm kind of?
I mean, there's some truth to that.
- Yeah, no, it was, I felt
like I was losing relevance
along the way, you know,
and trying to find other,
you know, media to sort of
stay in front of people,
but I also thought that
I wanted to take the time
to do it right because
if the point of the book
is to create experiences
that matter to people today
and that people are different.
- Then the book itself had to do that.
- It had to do that.
- Let me get into a rant,
because I like to rant.
My number one favorite thing of all time
is everybody who consults and gives advice
on using new technologies to sell stuff,
and then their books don't sell.
Like, I've, like, to me,
if the #AskGaryVee book is not a,
doesn't sell a lot of copies, then, like,
what is my, and to your
point there, right,
like, if you're own, like,
behavior doesn't map
the thesis, you're dead.
Like, and so, like, I'm
sure that you probably,
I noticed you brought in Mechanism,
a great agency, like, you
probably took a lot of thought
about that.
- Oh yeah, man, look.
I set the way not just as author,
but also acted as art
director, as researcher
to figure it out, because
it is my pet peeve, too,
go rant, so many authors
talk about the future
and how to be different, but they don't,
they're not different, right.
I mean, this is so different.
It's the shape of an iPad Air 2,
we had to come up with
all-new printing processes,
the paper, you know, if you just look
at the color saturation on the page,
you are jamming printers everywhere.
- Good job by, is it Wiley?
Good job by Wiley, willing
to allow you to like,
produce this, right?
They had a bet.
- Well, you know, they gave
Mechanism and I a shot,
and it's just, you swipe
right on it, you know.
- Alright, India.
It is time to get into the show.
- Show.
- A little classy that time.
- Yeah, I'm classy in my 40s.
Let's do it.
- [Voiceover] Andrew asks,
"How do you distinguish
"between bad marketing
strategy that's not working,
"and just having a crappy product?"
- Got it, so Andrew's been watching enough
to know that I talk a lot about, like,
even the best marketing in the world
isn't gonna fix your crap product.
So he's asking, how do we decipher?
Bri, do you wanna take a shot at that,
or do you want me to go?
- You go, and I'll add.
- You know, to me, it's pretty easy.
There's only those two
things at some level,
and so I think what you do first is,
if you're unsure, you
change your entire marketing
approach, and I would
say you do that twice.
So, over a 12-to-24 month period,
you change your marketing
approach radically.
If you go oh-for-three, there's chances
that your marketing
sucked all three times,
but it is starting to
give you an indication
that nobody wants your pet rock,
or your iPhone case
that glows in the dark,
or your crappy wine that you made.
So, the other thing to do is
to look at your lifetime value
and repeat business.
One of the reasons I know
that Wine Library works,
is we have incredible lifetime value,
and a lot of repeat business,
so then the waves of that
business are usually predicated
on the marketing, because
once we get people in,
they stay.
And so, I think we can feel
that as people that write books,
you'll look at your numbers this week,
and you probably will look at, like,
historically, since you've written seven.
What's your most successful book?
- End of Business As Usual
and Engage were, I think,
the most successful.
- Got it.
So, like, to me, like, it's funny,
I think that Thank You Economy
is the best book I wrote,
but it's the least successful,
and I look back at, like,
yeah, I gave it the less umph,
by far the least umph, because it was deep
in the starting of running VaynerMedia.
So, I think you look at lifetime
value and repeat business
and what your product is,
because if people are coming in
and they're using it and
buying or what have you,
well, then you just need to
figure out how to get more
of them in.
If you're getting a ton of
people in, but you're not getting
any long-tail action,
that's your vulnerability.
- And I think we live in
a time of social media,
right, and the key part of that is social,
so I think some of the best marketing
starts before the marketing, right,
so, listening, talking,
being inspired by people
through all these technologies
that humanize people
again and humanize communities.
I think you can actually take
that insight and build better
products, and build not just products,
but products that are experienced
and so that you can
invest in relationships
and lifetime value and retention
as well as acquisition.
- Love it, let's move it, India.
- [Voiceover] Elton says, "Hey, Gary,
"what do you think about the crying emoji
"being the Oxford word of the year?
"Communication shift?"
- I'm thrilled, I'm so
fired up about this,
you can't even imagine.
I think it's an important signal.
I've been talking about
communication shifting,
I use emojis, with 50-60 year
olds in the crowd saying,
how many of you have used emoji.
I just did a talk in Orlando,
ironically, two days before
I went, had to fly back and forth
for the Thursday night game,
I told you I was right
about that Bills-Jets.
Staphon, I'm on fire with my predictions.
Anyway, little quick shout-out
for all you Houston Texan
fans, I'll be in the
stadium on Sunday as well,
flying in and out for that game.
Going to every game this
year, I think I've decided.
I'm pumped, I think it's
a great, significant step,
it's a headline that a lot of
people are gonna come across
over the next 48 hours,
and it continues the thing
that I care about the most,
which is eliminating romance
and just dealing with the reality.
The world's changing,
pictures are clearly becoming
a way we communicate, emojis,
a lot of it happened in
Asia where the keypads,
and transitioned over here.
Listen, we used to draw on caves.
Like, inside caves, we drew on them.
Did they get mad when
the words came along?
Like, I'm sure there's,
like, grandpa caveman
was like, 'this is bullshit,' like,
'we should always draw on
cave, these words are bad,'
we get used to our norms, you know.
In 100 years from now when
we're only doing emoji-like
things, words are less used,
I mean, do you know how
much better my life is
that I actually misspell things on purpose
and let autocorrect fix them?
I don't romance over spelling improperly,
I just wanna get my words to somebody.
- We live in a time when
a magazine is an iPad
that doesn't work, so it'll work, too,
the folks at Oxford, I will
give you this response.
- Love it, love it.
- [Voiceover] Joel asks,
"Gary, what does the future look
like for the auto industry?
"Will local car dealers be cut
out of the business model?"
- It's a great question.
Look, I think direct-to-consumer over a
50 year period is very real,
and so, anybody who's, including
what I do for a living,
like, selling wine and liquor, like,
I do believe that the
internet is the middle man,
period, and I think a lot of industries
just haven't been affected by it yet.
So, the hotel industry's
been affected by it,
airBnB, the car, you know,
the black car industry's
been affected by it,
the bookstore industry's
been affected by it.
Systematically, over next half century,
most of the things that sell to customers
will be affected by it, and
I think auto is in play.
I mean, look, Tesla's selling direct,
so, I think that, yes, I do think,
now, I think way too many
people think about things,
and they think they're
gonna happen tomorrow.
I've learned that,
that's what I've learned.
Now that I'm 40 and wise, where I was 20,
I would've, if my 20-year-old
self was sitting here,
since Brian looks 20, according to Brian,
I'll say Brian, I'll say
Gary, 20-year-old Gary,
not everything's gonna
happen as fast as you think.
And that's the thing I've
learned, that it takes time,
but do I think over a 50-year period?
Absolutely.
If you're asking as a 48-year-old
who owns a car dealership,
I don't think you need
to sell it tomorrow,
but if you're asking as a 12-year-old
who wants to take over
grandpappy's dealership,
you may wanna consider going
in a different direction
then you're trying to
triple-down on the model.
Bri?
- I love car dealerships.
Said no one ever.
- That hurts.
- Look, I just actually
came off some research
with Google about this,
and we sent in the moments of truth about
the highly digital
customer shops for cars,
and I think there's an
opportunity for dealerships
to be relevant to today's society,
it's not based on yesterday's model.
- Sorry, just showing
my new kicks, go ahead.
- But, if you study it is, look
up autoshopping micromoments
and you will start to see exactly where
you add relevance and
value to the value chain,
but if you do not, Tesla-like
models are gonna take over,
and it's just inevitable, people
need to get what they want
when they want it, and how they want it.
- And things have been flow, like,
we used to have the downtown market, like,
the Main Street, American,
then we went to the suburbs,
and we had, you know,
supermarkets and Costco's,
and now, more than ever, people are moving
back into the cities, the
Detroits of the world,
and now you have Main
Street merging again,
so ebbs and flows, ebbs and flows,
and so technology overlaying
that is gonna cause
a lot of disruption
over the next 50 years,
and I do think the direct consumer model
is very real.
It's just economically
sound for the people
that the take the biggest risk,
who are the people that
actually make this crap.
- I think that just
reminded me of Clueless,
where the, rollin' with my homies.
- Rollin' with the homies.
God, I love that movie.
- [Voiceover] Joseph asks,
"Gary, how do you analyze all
the social media data
"that you get every day?
"Personally and corporately."
- What's the corporately part, like,
how does VaynerMedia do it versus me?
I do it completely on what got me here
in the first place, and Brian, you know,
this might be interesting, Brian,
it'd be interesting, this is
probably to make me feel good,
but you can go anywhere you want with it,
you have an interesting perspective,
because you were actually
there when my thing happened.
There's not that many people that were.
So, you know, I did it back then on feel.
I was right about a lot
of things intuitively,
and that's what I do now, I mean,
I just read it, I read my feeds,
I read my comments, I look
at the enagement levels
on what I'm putting out, so
I'm analyst on my own stuff.
Vayner as a corporate entity
is doing it much more
Excel sheet than gut feel
than I am, they're
analyzing numbers deeper,
they're converting that into a report
for their clients, I'm sure
you guys do similar stuff,
but me, personally, I'm just reading it.
Like, I'm watching how fast
I get likes on Instagram
when it's convenient, not every post.
You know, if I'm on a plane
and I do it right before
I take off, and as soon
as I get the Wi-Fi,
I can look at it, like,
there's kind of serendipity
to the way I analyze, but I'm feeling it.
I was very intuitive in
the way I marched in,
'06-7-8-9, a lot of
those things worked out.
I continue to do that, I continue, look,
I'm doing it even with the show.
If you're noticing, Brian
is now the culmination
of a period here where we
brought in a lot of guests
by comparison, so I'm
always testing and learning,
looking at the comments,
trying to understand,
trying to vibe with it.
Bri?
- The one thing I will say about you
as your friend, is that
you've always cared, right,
so at a time where, we've
come up with a lot of people
over the years that just
really try to buy into
the hype, create the hype, and really try
to grow their fan bases,
and all of that activity,
without actually adding
value to the community.
You're still hustling probably
harder than ever before,
maybe more than you did early on.
You take that feedback, I watched this,
you take that feedback, you
actually do something with it,
you do shows like this
where you can add value
to people's lives, people's streams,
with everything that you do,
so I think your metric
system is just sort of
a validation of the fact that
you're listening to people
and trying to give back to the community.
That's evident, and you
should be rewarded with that.
- Appreciate it.
You like that, India?
And by the way, by the
way, I have been asked
by 900 people to sit in this seat
and do this, and we've been at 6,
and, like, 5, and one of them
was my father-in-law,
so it's not, you know,
I think it speaks to your ways.
Well, and then there's all
the behind-the-scenes stuff
that you and I know, which is,
there's the business stuff,
and you can be very business-oriented,
this is a good lesson for
a lot of the youngsters,
there's the black-and-white
business stuff like,
'yo, homie, support my book?'
Sure, I could do that, but
then there's just life, right.
Like when somebody's sick,
when you post something on your Facebook
that you're having a tough time,
or the, all the people
that we share in common
that we've never sat
in the same room with,
that, how they talk about us to each other
when we get brought up
in a setting, right?
It's all those other things
that are part of the equation as well.
- You know, I think, if
there's one thing I've learned
along this journey is to constantly give
more than you take and.
- 51-49.
- Treat people in ways that
make them feel more special
when they leave an engagement with you,
and then, last is, just
live and act and breathe
as if you want people to talk about you
when you're not in the room
in a way that's complimentary.
- 100%.
Legacy and brand.
- [Voiceover] Meet asks, "Hi, Gary,
"it seems like everyone speaks about
"not giving up no matter what,
"but how do you know when
it's time to let it go?"
- So, I'm, this is
something I struggle with,
like, having a loss on
your resume is so scary,
and the business ventures that I've had
in the past where I
wasn't actively running
and I've talked about Cork'd or Forrst.
Lindsay and Kyle, amazing entrepreneurs
that I don't feel that I supported enough
and thus those two, Obsessed
TV with Samantha Ettus,
where I try to produce a video show,
that didn't start me.
I never was able to give it enough energy,
and the thing I spent
the most time with is
when do I let it go?
Because there's a point where you realize,
by the way, I realize this with employees,
you know, I know a lot
of VaynerMedia employees
watch this, but I'm gonna tell the truth.
There's 5 to 6 employees that I think
it might be time to not
work together anymore,
and do I struggle with that?
Boy, do I struggle with that.
One, mainly because I don't
like letting other people down
more than anything.
The truth is, Meet, I think
this is a very personal answer.
I think it depends on every individual,
but what I will say is, way
too many people watching this
right now are holding onto
hope, or a non-reality,
or don't wanna make somebody feel bad,
or dont wanna have the
reputation of having a loss
on their record, and I
think that's a huge mistake,
and it's probably the mistake
I'm most vulnerable to,
and as I think about my next 40 years
of executing, and you're right,
I am hustling more than ever,
I'm feeling more fit and energized
and feel like I'm gonna really
go into my golden years,
especially the next 20
years, that's just the truth,
though I'm sure when I'm 60 I'm like,
this is when I'm really gonna do it.
I do think that that, this
is a tremendous question,
I'm so goddamn pumped that this happened
on my 40th, post-40th
birthday episode, first one.
This is the one thing that
I'm spending a lot of time on.
I think it's hard, but it is,
I think more people have
to let go more often.
And the two things that I'm working on
are both ends of that:
saying no more often,
because boy that's hard for me,
and then letting go more
often, and really zoning in
on that middle is my answer to that.
So the punchline is, very personal, but,
because I wanna bring value
to everybody listening,
what's up, podcasters, and watching,
I really think that a lot of
you need to take this question,
use it as a moment, use it as permission,
let me be your olive branch,
link to this part of
the show as the excuse
or the frame that let you do it,
there's a lot of people
that need to let go.
- And if I could have one thing,
that would be,
this book is probably the
first time where I felt
like I was gonna fail in a while.
- Interesting, because you,
because you had to do the work?
It wasn't like what naturally was in you.
- Right, it was, what was naturally in me
was just write another book, you know,
and I thought that I would
be letting everyone down
by doing that, and in three
and a half years in the making,
right, there were, I mean,
even up until six weeks before
it was done, I thought
it was not gonna happen.
- Meaning what?
- Just, so many things
were going wrong, you know,
in terms of production
and printing processes
and finding the right shapes
and everything about it.
Also, re-learning how to write sentences.
Like, I was beaten.
And there was a saying
that a friend of mine,
Adele Ressie, had told me that,
an entrepreneurship,
it's always the darkest
before the dawn.
And I thought that, yo, maybe that is it,
maybe this was just a test
to go a little bit further
and see it through, but at the same time,
it was the right thing to do,
but at the same time, there are moments
when you have to walk away,
and just try to learn from them,
because that's all anybody wants from you
is to show that you tried
and that you learned
from something and that you did it better
or did it differently the next time.
- Appreciate it, my friend.
As the guest of today's show,
you get to ask the Vayner Nation,
I've been back to the question of the day.
You get to ask them any question.
This is a great opportunity,
I know you like focus groups and data.
There'll be a lot of answers
on YouTube and Facebook,
and I'll send you the link
so you can go through them.
Here's your shot.
You wanna make it the
theme of that, you thing,
whatever you wanna go with.
Talk about the New York Jets.
- As I think about just even my own work,
is, you know, if you could
maybe close your eyes
and think about, you
know, when's the last time
you had a really great experience
with something, whether
it was a brand or service
or anything, and what was it?
- Do you have one, India?
- And what made it so special?
- Do you have one, do you
have something really.
- [Kelly] That was mine.
- What was?
No, no, I'm sorry, do you
have a great experience.
The last great experience,
do you have something
that's, like, just so obvious?
- It is a hard one.
- It's interesting, it all
depends on what you decide.
The Four Seasons is where
I stayed with my family.
There was a problem, and
that was the opportunity
for the great experience.
I secretly thought that
you should do things wrong
on purpose, because I
think there's more upside
in the fixing a mistake,
than just normal status.
Like, if you were just
crushing it as a rest,
nobody here's like, oh, this restaurant,
because they consist, let's
say there's a restaurant
that you go to that
consistently hits it on a 9.5
on the scale of the world.
9.5, you know how insane that is?
Like it is on point.
After the third or fourth time
you just take it for granted.
Like if you went there the first time
and, like, the waiter spilt red wine over
your beautiful dress, India be cool
because she wears black
and so you wouldn't
be able to see it, but, but, like,
if you, you got some white today.
You know, if that happened,
and then they comped the whole meal,
and, like, picked you up
and carried you to your car,
or gave you, it's so funny
to me that mistake first,
fixing the mistake is a greater experience
for a lot of people.
I would add on as a point B,
a great experience that wasn't predicated
on a problem at first.
Loved having you on, brother.
Buy the book, he deserves
it, it's a good man.
Thanks for coming on.
You keep asking questions,
we'll keep answering them.
(upbeat, techno music)